Oh oh my god
Syd we have so much to do so much to
talk about and stuff
you're very kind oh my god love you as
Wow very kind no [ __ ] one of the
things I thought about on the table was
just like ah [ __ ] man I won't get to do
that show at that place anymore and here
we are so yeah all right welcome the fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I am mark
Renard big night tonight ladies and
gentlemen my wife is in the house
Jennifer not coz she wanna be she just
wants to [ __ ] watch me make sure that
don't happen again and stuff she's got
me I'm Mike yeah totally closer she's in
very very and Nurse Jackie mode and
she's in a good way not a druggie way
and she's been all over me and so she's
here tonight which is really really
sweet
yes how are you what do you been up to
my my the highlight of my last week was
I was in my food court yeah I've told
you about my food court right yeah they
know me there by now so I have to get a
new food court but I was uh it must have
been like last Wednesday or so yes and
I'm sitting there right now doing my
[ __ ] work and some dude comes up the
escalator sees me working he's like hey
you like Bernard and I'm like yeah
saying I love the black pants around
tables like oh man thanks he's like you
know what
tell Kemp to keep his [ __ ] chin up
and get better he's everybody's brother
and I was like you know what amen
that is literally all I've been up to
what what are you been doing I don't
know if you know this or not but I had a
little episode last week I had a heart
attack and survived it this is the mote
this is the one ass I've talked about in
so many other places so I won't belabor
the topic but I will say this is the
only place where I could really talk
about this on fat man I'm Batman like my
whole life I never had a super villain I
have one now the [ __ ] Widowmaker and
I feel the Widowmaker man so that felt
kind of metal it feels great to be here
man I love you guys all know I love
doing the show I love coming to the
space and stuff I love the scum and
villainy Cantina here on Hollywood
Boulevard put your hands together to the
folks at home know your real so it's you
know of course it's nice to be above
grounds nice to be anywhere but it's
really [ __ ] nice to be doing
something as trivial as talking about
pop culture like you know in the bar
that's that's my kind of normal and I'm
happy to get back to it I saw my
cardiologist today I have one of those
now I never had one of those ah you got
a heart day I do have a heart guy he's
like you and I are gonna become best
friends he told that to me while I was
[ __ ] going up my groin and
catheterized
so dargor late and I'm I went to see him
today
and it's he took my blood pressure seems
everything's going great he showed me a
model of my heart and what had happened
and walked me through it and stuff like
that he came in with a prop I was like
props he was like I knew you'd like that
we went through it and I'm in a really
good place right now you know he's like
now you know what to expect like going
forward if you ever feel that again
[ __ ] first you put nitro tablet under
your tongue and if five minutes you'd
still feel bad do it again and [ __ ]
call me fast and [ __ ] so it the one
thing I do want to just stress to others
because it seems to resonate is that I
was expecting you know I was raised on
pop culture and [ __ ] like that so I
expected a heart attack to be like Fred
Sanford like let's bed I'm coming you
know like very dramatic and you're
clutching at your chest and screaming
and [ __ ] like that I didn't realize I
was having a heart attack
did not feel what I assumed a heart
attack would feel like I wasn't really
in pain the whole time they kept going
like what's your pain number Man 1 to 10
and I was like - and they're like - put
the horror fiend down you know because
they were getting ready - they thought
his EKG shows that he's had a massive
heart attack but I wasn't really in pain
I know that's not this case for every
heart attack but [ __ ] I didn't really
realize it was going on and now in
retrospect I had two episodes prior to
this that were probably like warning
signs at 85% and 95% blockage where it
finally busted through I was a hundred
percent blockage that night so nothing
was going to get through that hard
rhinestone so now I know what to look
for but for those of you out there who
are you know have heart conditions or
evil arge like me and [ __ ] like that and
you're like yeah man that [ __ ] scares
me number one go get checked out like it
we got pretty decent healthcare in this
country and stuff it's worth looking
into
because you know you could be saving
your own life but number two if if you
feel if you ever feel like this is what
happened to me I was I felt like I had
caught a cold I'd talked to some people
after the show and then I went into my
green room and I was like oh man I feel
like I just suddenly caught a cold like
one of those [ __ ] I talked to
had a dirty [ __ ] bug and they just
gave it to me piece of [ __ ] and so as I
was ruminating about that it started to
spread and it wasn't a cold suddenly I
was sweating but I sweat when I [ __ ]
breathe so that was nothing new
but this was profuse like buckets and
[ __ ] like that I threw up didn't like I
didn't know that was associated with
potential heart attack felt nauseous
threw up and [ __ ] like that
and and ultimately there was no you know
there like did it feel like there was a
car on your chest no not at all
I just couldn't catch a full breath I'd
be like it's very shallow I couldn't go
up to the top and come back down again
so if you ever feel that kind of [ __ ]
and you're like oh it can't be a heart
attack
it is a [ __ ] heart attack pay
attention to it listen to your body but
don't do like I did don't wait go get
yourself [ __ ] checked out and stuff
so I I just I may have mentioned it
online this is not a call or you know
spiritual choice but by default I have
now become vegan they've kind of taken
the animal products out of my life
I'm not part of your cult not [ __ ]
happy about it but I understand it will
save my life and [ __ ] and so I you know
lately I've been taking it like
justifying it by being like hey man for
47 years I whatever the [ __ ] I want it
for the last 25 of that particularly
when I was my own person and [ __ ] like
from clerks forward I was like I could
do whatever I want now and [ __ ] I
would just eat cake for [ __ ] meals
and [ __ ] like that I mean there's eggs
in it there's milk in it yeah so if
[ __ ] diet it's the one good thing
Bill Cosby ever gave us was the listen
you guys I mean oh I lived through the
Widowmaker don't bring up Phil [ __ ]
Cosby man feeling good about like [ __ ]
but yes I I ate whatever I wanted for
years and then was just like I'm at this
place now where I'm like [ __ ] it you did
whatever you wanted now you had your fun
now try it the other way [ __ ] him for
five years not even I'm not even saying
give me 47 years of being a [ __ ]
vegan or whatever just try it that way
so I was talking to this dude who I
started working this program with Penn
Jillette of Penn & Teller
Adam Rifkin and the director was friend
I'm friends with he had emailed me after
the heart attack and it was like hey I
know Penn Jillette and he lost like a
hundred pounds after his heart thing do
you want to talk to him and I know Penn
a little bit he came over the house
years ago did podcast with us and stuff
and I've been a Penn & Teller fan for
[ __ ] ever going way too [ __ ] back so
I said yeah I might [ __ ] I'll talk to
anybody at this point like how do you
live you know I just want to know and
[ __ ] so I got in touch with him and
first thing he said was like I got a guy
but the programs little extreme have you
ever read my book presto he's like buy
my book read it and if you're still
interested we could talk about it and
stuff so I said is it book on tape and
he said yes and I read it and I said
that's perfect so I got that listen to
the [ __ ] book and fell in love with
this program it reminded me of when I
cut sugar out of my life and stuff he's
the kind of personality like me where he
can just dial in if somebody's like do
this you know like yes and especially if
you're seeing results and he didn't
stuff so I liked what was said as so
much I was like you know what I'm ready
to do this and stuff so he hooked me up
with the guy his name is Ray
a pen calls him creare and so I just met
with ray today about going forward and
stuff with this program of his because I
got a cut wait that's part of it the
doctor was just like you got to lose
weight and I was like I know I lost like
I'd lost 90 pounds like in the last two
three years and they were like keep
going you know that's great yeah it's
like [ __ ] I thought like the bronze is
fine with me but I like go for a gold
[ __ ] you like a cookie no no
cookies keep losing totally so I so [ __ ]
where was I
creamy so I met with cray I was just in
Calabasas and met with him and stuff
and I told them I was like you know my
philosophy of like I've [ __ ] had my
fun and he goes you're going about it
all wrong he's going the fun's about to
happen
I was like all right I know the fun of
vegetables'
and Annie but I mean he had this really
great point which was like you know I
told him at one point I was like I hate
vegetables he goes no you don't and I
was like yeah bro I do and he goes no
you don't that's just a story you tell
people this story you tell yourself all
the time that way you don't have to eat
vegetables and stuff he goes but have
you ever really try any and I gave it a
thought and I was like I've never tried
99 percent of the vegetables in the
world so he's like okay so he's like you
know what salt and sugar and and fat
tastes like [ __ ] I mean we all love that
and [ __ ] like that he's gone but imagine
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna taste now
if you take that out of your life you go
there's a bunch of [ __ ] you've never
eaten by default you just say you don't
like it so he's going you gotta flip the
script so I liked it it's not gonna mind
[ __ ] I'm like alright you're tricking
me that's so I'm gonna start that in
earnest on Thursday and not because of
Mike and tomorrow I'm gonna eat some
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright you know it's
based on what happened to me like I you
know I love I love my life of eating
[ __ ] bless you animal you know
products animal related products and
[ __ ] but it's time to shut it down
there's other ways to have a good time
and I also have to break my [ __ ]
romance with food a lot of food for me
is reward based so like look even though
they look at me I look like a fat [ __ ] I
spend most bless you I spend most of my
day not eating until it's like eight
o'clock at night and then I'm like I'm
done now I've earned the
right to sit here and watch a program
and eat food and I will watch it
two-hour movie and eat feed the whole
time and you're not supposed to [ __ ]
do that but that was like a man that's
led what I like to do as an adult and so
when I told ray today I was like I don't
like vegetables because well grow up
what are you five and it was just that
kind of realism like you have my
attention keep slapping me across the
face of the big [ __ ] dick of logic
and also I don't wear pants I pretty
much am five I wear shorts and a
baseball hat everywhere I go I dressed
like an infant I forget like an infant
and [ __ ] like that
I got the Peanuts gang yeah it's got to
change speaking the Peanuts gang look at
my [ __ ] new jersey it's me a lark and
since I was done by Paul Quinn a long
time ago as Charlie Brown you were done
as Franklin it's never like hey we can
make you like a Drusilla but if it just
was a [ __ ] peanuts character I'll be
weird if I look like Charlie Brown you
look like Idris Elba it's a long lot of
shoe leather on that joke that I have to
explain I was like well mark always
wanted to look like Idris Elba I guess
because he's not an idiot and maybe
that'd be great for him I thought he'd
be happy he was on my Jersey at all but
he wanted a better depiction I I didn't
approve that all right so yeah I had a
heart attack and I survived and we're
here now to talk about [ __ ] pop
culture this is the thing I've been
looking forward to since I got out the
hospital they canceled my Babylon last
weekend and [ __ ] without asking me and I
was so fit last one the one they
canceled bastard I was like [ __ ] I
wanted to do that sure like you just
died [ __ ] so this is the one I was
really hoping that it canceled and they
didn't and we're here to do it man so
let's [ __ ] get the show on
what do we got to talk about man one
thing I can't wait to talk about can I
lead with it because because she's
hopping my head I mean don't know one
thing I read in the hospital I said this
is a [ __ ] thing worth living for
Kristen Wiig might play [ __ ] cheetah
in the Wonder Woman movie yes
that's I didn't dream that the drug
narcolepsy a [ __ ] like I'm dying
a real thing I'll miss your dreams come
true my friend [ __ ] that's a good idea
man
yeah well now do you think they make her
cheetah like half is she cheetah in an
outfit or she cheetah like I'm [ __ ]
island of dr. Moreau
I think it's cheating in that fit if I
had to guess like lots of leopard print
no actually leopard DNA will she have
little ears and [ __ ] not just like I
don't want a leopard scarf she gotta
wear the stupid [ __ ] outfit otherwise
she's not cheetah as far as I'm
concerned maybe they do it the way they
did with Luke Cage where it's just like
here's the one scene where you see him
in the [ __ ] disco yellow shirt and
the headband and the chain-link belt and
he looks himself in a mirror and says
sweet Christmas I buy that yeah I'll
take the cage sweet walls whoo you
haven't missed a beat my friend anyway
that's the one news story that I had
that I was sitting in my back in my mind
going [ __ ] I want to see that yeah
that's why I clawed back from the land
of the dead I was like [ __ ] you
Widowmaker wigs go to play cheetah and
my wife
good good good cover yeah well done
yeah and I have the thing that I
realized from that news story I always
thought because we talked about those
the Wonder Woman was gonna be the Cold
War yeah but I was imagining like 50s
Cold War like just after the post war
when like the wall is still up and [ __ ]
like that
this is in the 80s that's where they're
setting it yeah is that where Captain
Marvel said as well I think so yeah yeah
there's a weirdness for me like the 80s
the fashion just [ __ ] me up like that
is not a thing I actually want to see on
the big screen you don't ever want to
see a piano tie again for the rest of
your life yeah somebody with a random
keytar isn't that what I'm looking for
they did that in that one x-men movie
they went to the 80s and stuff yeah
apocalypse which I choose to never
acknowledge is an x-men movie yes all
right well what do you think what's the
story if you had to guess it takes place
in the 80s what is that nuclear war run
I think so I think it's like you know
the arms race its proliferation its
class said it right now that was the end
of my political humor we've talked about
the hard stuff I mean it could be that
whole thing it could be you know I don't
[ __ ] know Minutemen Missile Crisis
ease and that kind of [ __ ] like I don't
know there's there's a story there for
sure I'm just not quite as excited as I
was about like awesome sixty suits and
pre James Bond intrigue and you know
shuttling back and forth across the
Berlin Wall like that should all sound
it fun patty Jenkins yep I'm on board
they could do whatever they want if
they're like she's gonna sit there and
[ __ ] read for two hours I'm billing
write on as long as the lassos in view
I'm good
alright where are we going what do you
got the rest of the news did I did you
watch the Oscars over the weekend I want
a attention last hour not because I'm
like too good for that [ __ ] I totally
would have watched it but Scott Mosier
who has not been in town for like a good
year he's been over in France working
for illumination their cartoon people
was in town and he came over and we
SModcast and shouldn't I haven't seen
him since the heart attack I didn't see
him in [ __ ] a long time so we were
doing that and that wound up going late
into the night
and then I came back to the bedroom when
he left and Jennifer was still watching
it was like an hour left so I saw like
the that's not a good [ __ ] right the the
thing that astonishes me about this
year's Oscars was that a giant [ __ ]
monster movie won Best Picture like yeah
I let it out flat out like that it's not
a if that doesn't get Creature from the
Black Lagoon [ __ ] greenlit I don't
know what does man but it's not even
like it's a metaphorical monster who's
in luck no it's a [ __ ] fish dude yeah
who spoilers she Fox yeah so it got
going for it as well it could so
bestiality you call the first I believe
you said it was your favorite movie of
the year and I was like what really [ __ ]
and then I saw it I was like a good love
it it is a beautiful
it's everything cinema should be and
he's like a darling [ __ ] man who like
cinema runs in his [ __ ] blood like he
deserved there was no no moment man
where I was like him I'm like I get it
this guy [ __ ] deserves it and [ __ ]
like that I know somewhere in Trump's
America people like that's not third
Mexican that stole an Oscar from an
American but like hey man like this kids
imagination kid he's older than me his
[ __ ] imagination is beautiful like
every time he steps up to bat he [ __ ]
really swings for it and this time it
connected with the audience in an
emotional way I was happy for him very
fun but you know the fact that that's a
Best Picture winner yeah is phenomenal
like and the Best Screenplay winners get
out a shout out film two shots these
honors films yeah you know I was I was
pulling for for some kind of split
between get out and and shape of water
for picture and director but I feel like
screenplay is actually the right thing
for get out because agreed you know like
that it is such a the work of that
movies on the page the work of that
movie is let me tell you a fable let me
tell you a story about race and class
and gender and and assimilation and all
of that [ __ ] while [ __ ] with your
brain because it's a really taut
thriller I know what a long time ago I
agree with you but I'm gonna add
something to it and it's gonna go back
and try to correct some history a long
time ago in a book that my friend wrote
John Pierce he wrote a book called spike
Mike slackers and dykes
I had this discussion as a young
filmmaker at the [ __ ] first year of
my career where I was like I think of
Quentin
no more as a writer than a director is
amazing writer he's a fine director he's
an amazing [ __ ] writer and years
later we had a comic book store in
Westwood a Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash and I wasn't there some kids ran
and [ __ ] one night somebody running it
Quentin came in he was eaten at the
place next door and he goes this Kevin
Smith's place and she said yeah totally
and he's like is that that book that
because we had on display copies of old
copies spike Mike slackers and Ikes they
picked up that book and he goes do you
know he once said that I wasn't as good
a director as I was a writer in this
[ __ ] book and you know the person
who's working the [ __ ] front counter
was like yeah he's an idiot we don't
respect him at all so I agree with you
that now this is a long way of saying
years later I realized what a ridiculous
[ __ ] statement that is he's brilliant
[ __ ] director brilliant filmmaker
he's also a brilliant [ __ ] writer and
stuff but back in those days I was a
writer snob a writer who was the most
important thing to me you're right that
script is [ __ ] brilliant and he does
deserve to win for screenplay but he had
a credible shot as director because that
movie has nuance in a signature it has a
style to it it's memorable there's a lot
of symmetry and the shots like that's
not the work of somebody who's just like
you know oh I got lucky
like he's clearly got the gift way more
than [ __ ] I do so much so it's a
visually stunning arresting movie like
when he drops was that area called the
sunken place the sunken place yeah
that's [ __ ] crimson that's a horrible
[ __ ] mesmerizing the visual that has
to come from someplace to communicate to
the audience I never could have thought
of something like that yeah but and
that's also a dude who like trained
himself in key and Peele every every
skip in key and Peele was a movie and
while Peter Atencio
was the director who did almost
everything on key and Peele [ __ ] key
and Peele were there the whole [ __ ]
time you know and Peele clearly was a
dude who wanted to do this himself he
said I mean he said it when he accepted
he's like there are 20 times I tried to
start this movie and put it
because I was like it'll never happen
and [ __ ] so don't stop take it to its
logical logical conclusion don't hurt
anybody in the process but like you know
[ __ ] everybody's dream is valid and
[ __ ] and his panned out the big bad way
yeah the one time I've been a journalist
on and off for about 25 years and the
one exclusive I ever [ __ ] broke
because I was never that dude I never
cared about news other than making the
news look good and read well right the
one excuse I've ever got was I got
invited to the Samsung was having some
event in the Hollywood Hills it was like
college basketball or football whatever
the hell it was and and I was gonna
interview Jordan to do some quick like
wrote Q&A that we used to have on
Playboy calm it was like Lucky seven and
there were seven questions we asked
everybody and we get to the end of the
interviews I go [ __ ] Jordan peels
here great I'll talk to Jordan about it
and we get to the interview he goes all
right listen I'm gonna give you some
news my managers not gonna want to tell
you this but I'm writing a horror movie
this is like four years ago I'm not
what's a car like it's get out I'm like
oh [ __ ] like that Eddie Murphy sketch I
remember when I saw the poster I was
just like oh my god is the gaby Murphy's
real awesome we have so much fun here
the kids can be happy yeah it's time to
go wellhow man so he told you he told me
I broke the story the one exclusive of
Playboy at the time the ones who
survived ever had was Jordan Peele was
writing and directing a horror movie
it's great when have in retrospect isn't
that [ __ ] won an Oscar so hey I did
that you're welcome buddy
what else did anything else Yama
Oriented win or anything of note that
would matter in our world no but here's
the one thing that the the snub if
that's such a thing I'm the most pissed
off about is that War of the Planet of
the Apes
none of those Planet of the Apes movies
have ever won a special-effects Oscar
okay and what the [ __ ] like the whole
movie is talking monkeys and orangutangs
and chimpanzees I don't want to be like
an atheist so
I will absolutely look at APIs
acknowledge every tribe of the simian
kingdom but none of them given given the
fact that every major character every
major performance is done by a dude in
dots on his face
yes rendered by computer and that
doesn't win best special effects is
beyond me
what did Blade Runner which is beautiful
but yeah I'm a can see your argument
yeah I wouldn't have to do all so I was
gonna say I forget who I voted for but I
don't know if I'm allowed to say
whatever they get kind of shitty and
weird like if you were more picks
instead I mean I I was close this year
when I look at the end results those ago
I didn't I love Dallas and Janie and I
Tanya but I'm an old school Roseanne fan
and I loved Larry Mac thank you
Laurie Metcalf in ladybird ladybird was
transcendent filmmaking there is it like
I was glad Greta Gerwig got dominated
that was a wonderful film to make me
give a [ __ ] about life in Sacramento
back then like then that performance was
wonderful like a fantastic movie I love
that I loved the shape of water of
course now here's a flick I saw since we
did a show do you see [ __ ] Florida
project no beautiful yes oh my god is so
[ __ ] human is so so beautiful and
it's got one of the most magical and
tragic endings I've ever seen in a
[ __ ] motion picture at haunting
beautiful but this guy got he's same guy
who directed tangerine the iPhone Shaun
Baker says name sure will say his name
he got he's not for Mance's out of these
[ __ ] kids that's it's otherworldly
like to the best child performance on
film I've ever seen since the Bad News
Bears 1976 like those kids were
believable in [ __ ] these kids in this
movie are [ __ ] I I don't think they
were actually working with this script I
think he just put cameras on him and he
would say things to him and he would
just [ __ ] get that and build around
it is it's wonderful I don't want to
spoil the movie for you but it's it's
it's about people you never think of
Wow so and that's you know in an indie
film that's what I look for the most
like in mainstream movies you know it's
like show me Iron Man stories but when
it comes to like indie film
show me something show me a snapshot
into a world I've never seen because
that's how I got my start the only
reason anyone knows my [ __ ] name is
because I showed a snapshot into some
weird little world that people hadn't
seen before so like I I loved that
discovery this movie was absolute [ __ ]
discovery for me it's so [ __ ] good I
was a little bummed that that didn't it
will him to folk that was it that was
better
what else can I make a prediction for
next year's Oscars yes
Black Panther will win two Oscars okay
I'm not gonna say which but I will I am
gonna take bets right now how did this
end 100 percent lock well the ones to
best that they got to remember like a
year from now no they will because you
know how much money this movie's made
already tell us nine hundred and five
million dollars worldwide Oh in six
weeks there was all of the monies yes
Wakanda forever heaven and ever and ever
so they're easily gonna hit a billion
they can hit a billion by like next
Thursday
and how many other characters in their
stable have done that like ant-man
didn't get to a billion no it is the it
is the highest-grossing aside from
Ironman Ironman is the only other solo
cat first one went to a billion no Iron
Man three went to a billion right Wow
so not since Iron Man 3 has a standalone
movie gone to a billion for them yeah
it's taken Avengers to do yeah and now
Civil War and so what did that go to a
billion yet so that everybody that every
hero and stuff wow that's huge bragging
rights and stay yeah I wonder if we'll
get a sequel well I mean you heard that
that I'm not sure if you were
convalescing at the moment but but
Marvel pushed up the release date for
Avengers infinity war but yet another
reason to stay alive I was like another
way girlier fantastic yeah I can do this
what now why is that I'm not I'm not
looking to gift horse in the mouth
that's awesome but why I think the the
way that it was working was it was
opening May 5th for us but it was
opening April 27th internationally
and so my gut is they kill somebody
[ __ ] huge and didn't want that
information to slip out from Paris now
that makes sense now my next question is
do you really mean to tell me the only
thought of that like two weeks ago
they're like after all that careful
planning like oh [ __ ] we forgot like
this smells like marketing of the
highest order
yeah like let's stagger these dates
because then like the last month before
the movie comes out we'll put them
together we'll look metal as fog and
great plan and like saying I enjoy a bit
of showmanship and [ __ ] like that but
there's no way that they only just
realized recently like oh [ __ ] this is
stupid we should have a come out day and
date all over yeah except they didn't
tell anybody else and so Amy Schumer had
a movie opening on April 27th her I feel
pretty movie and she was like what the
[ __ ] we had the day to ourselves this
was ours we were gonna roll it'll be
amazing and then now you're
counter-programming yeah now they're on
April 20th because they were like moved
in they moved they they did not want to
play chicken rampage moved as well
everything is everything is shifting
shifting is a word right no in Dublin
maybe yeah maybe instead of shuffling
shuffling shuffling I'll [ __ ] nail
everything it's great we get to see our
favorite heroes a week earlier like that
and we don't have to hear from some
[ __ ] Frenchman what happens to Tony
Stark
whoa did you see what I see with our own
American eyes this shot blow is the more
you say mark shirt it's pretty genius
man yeah Chat Noir Sherry's Chawla is
the Shatner
[Music]
not really
don't sexualize mark I mean all right go
ahead
sexual do it but do it slowly do small
chili what's next in the news department
uh chris hemsworth you know
he's attractive i hear i want to [ __ ]
that dude a whole Hemsworth let's be
honest I'd let him [ __ ] me yeah he's
pretty amazing looking is that the other
thing you're gonna do different this
second yeah
you know what I survived the Widowmaker
I'm gonna tell you all the Hollywood
studs I'm gonna [ __ ] before I die no
meat except that meat yeah like a
plant-based diet yeah get my vegan
daughter would probably sign off on that
she's like it's fine dad as long it's
does not animal product robot cocked
okay alright so wait chris hemsworth
clearly this man does not want to leave
a franchise behind is going to be one of
the men in black oh yes sony is
rebooting men in black he's legit funny
funnier than he should be given that he
looks the way he looks
I know he's problematically pretty even
very funny at the same time like that
was supposed to be our thing I know it's
like you get to be pretty we get to be
witty he's like no I'll get him both
good for him that makes sense the wait
there's a tie-in to K and J or I think
it will but not na we're ever gonna see
time Lee Jones and Will Smith in black
suits again but I feel like that's the
it's in the universe it's in continuity
but he's just one of the new guys I'm ok
with that don't you don't have to
[ __ ] like undo it and be like no it's
brand new like I'd like it more if it
was connected and they don't have to
bring those characters back if they
don't want to and [ __ ] but as long as
there's some pictures hanging up and
they're like hey there was a guy right
I'm cool with that said it in the same
world don't reboot that's smart yeah so
he's going to be the the white one and
and they are I think they go reverse
order this time it was the old white guy
younger black guy maybe this time is
younger what guy older black guy they
are going black woman Oh racist and
sexist game holy [ __ ] we call and raise
wow man that's smart yeah who would it
be my gut they haven't announced
anything yet
I feel like Tiffany Haddish is on the
head of just about every list oh my god
that's so [ __ ] smart
I want to see the movie that doesn't
exist you just that's a really great
idea that's [ __ ] smart she's funny
yeah funny you know I think that
Hemsworth verse 20 CDs he's also a
really good straight man ya know because
for much of ragnarok he's the straight
man yeah you know but he still gets the
pole you still have a couple of jokes
but he is not mr. punchline which is
fine and [ __ ] Tiffany Haddish is on
fire I like that it's got my approval
watch the movie to get concept you keep
going totally so when is this out June
June 14 29 teen I'll be dead by then no
I'm here man I'm here I'm here to stay
I'll be Belva here well you can't get
rid of me that easy I'll be giving you
my worthless opinion when that movie
comes out right from this space
goddammit hell yeah even if the bars
closed
[Music]
[Applause]
no there used to be a Star Wars bar oh
yeah
where are we going next um did you were
you a Sandman fan mm-hm
were I that's what lab you still are of
course you don't lose your fandom for
that [ __ ] you don't outgrow dream and
the Dreaming I thought I've nearly met
his sister death and now you're in
delirium Neil Gaiman is not rebooting is
the wrong word he's continuing the
Sandman universe he is Francesca the
same way the drug wave franchise young
animal yeah he's got his own Sandman
imprint at vertigo so he's gonna oversee
a bunch of Sandman related titles yes
that's so smart he has his own IP that
he created an entire universe
totally keep it going maybe we don't
attic and so yeah it's launching in
August with the Sandman universe number
one with Gaiman we'll plot and then
there's four other books there's the
dreaming Tim hunter in the books of
magic and then Lucifer there do another
Lucifer book
wow man [ __ ] in the late 80s early 90s
are back thank Christ man that's that's
awesome
good for him so smart he's been very
prolific lately finally got good omens
made it looks like he's been deeply
involved in that production as well
American Gods last year they're going on
to another season
he's on fire man he deserves it so
[ __ ] talented that guy and sweet
heart of a man he's the nicest guy so
[ __ ] nice I remember the first time I
met him because I met him like a dozen
times because that's how I roll but he
told me that that's it came in you just
whipped out your game and dick I did
yeah he told me that Sandman was the
first sexually transmitted comic book in
that the way would work was that dudes
would buy it their girlfriends would
read it their girlfriends to break up
with those dudes because they're awful
and then bring the same books to another
dude and then that dude to read it break
up with a girl and it would be this
diaspora of San man fans because they're
all [ __ ] each other Wow
yeah interesting I mean look who would
know except him right yeah - he's
probably meets fandom and they probably
tell him over and over again like I
[ __ ] someone and read your book and
then I stop [ __ ] them and now I'm
[ __ ] someone else and they love your
book so it's bechet's based on empirical
was at the DC booth one year at
comic-con and he was signing there and I
was way down the [ __ ] aisle signing
my own little dumb [ __ ] comic book and I
saw somebody come up to him and ask for
an autograph he said now of course I'm
happy to do it on her arm half an hour
later she comes back with the tattoo of
the signature that he just drew her arm
yeah yeah that is a level of Fame I do
not understand yeah I never will I've
met a few people who are like so high my
arm I'm gonna get a tattoo and I was
like rethink your choices like one day
and hopefully it's not soon but I assure
you one day you're gonna wake up and be
like I don't even like these movies and
you're gonna look at your arm and
realize my [ __ ] name is on it don't
do it but I've met many people have done
it's very flattering it's tough wait go
back though yeah what were we talking
about before the tattoo Sandman Sandman
Gaiman did a voice in J's cartoon movie
J made a cartoon movie called Jay and
Silent Bob's super groovy cartoon movie
and he was the voice of Albert the
butler and he was so lovely came in and
did like complete like just performance
for us and stuff and you know we've been
friends for a while but he was like
nobody ever asked me to act and he's so
[ __ ] good so if you ever want to hear
Neil Gaiman making butt [ __ ] jokes
watch super-groovy car dude movie I am
also in that movie that's right bandy
the boys there as well you were down the
[ __ ] hall from him for the signing but
you were shoulder to shoulder in the
middle we really weren't yeah I was the
mayor of Red Bank all right where are we
going next we got one more Neil Gaiman
though that's a good [ __ ] idea I mean
think about it you can turn that [ __ ]
movies they've been trying to turn
Sandman into
for damn near 25 years now yeah always
[ __ ] coming up short this because you
don't need it to be a movie episodic TV
now you give them 10 [ __ ] episodes 20
episodes even those storylines were deep
and rich and mythic like I I would love
that
I would love before I leave this world
to see a Sandman series we're gonna have
to make a list of the [ __ ] you want to
see before you leave this yes it's all
slowly to stay it's paid 73 if the [ __ ]
kid wants to see in this world the
problem is one day they're gonna make it
all because its content and we're here
world and then they're gonna be like now
what I'm gonna be like now it's time to
die where we going to Luke we'll all
want to die at that point I assure you
because we'll all be old then we push
the cross over to it's an X on top of
your on top of your grave Wow
too soon make my wife cry left by now
[Laughter]
Last Story
really yeah wow that's fast I mean we
had other [ __ ] to talk about that's true
I mean Keanu Reeves is making a
superhero movie that's all right a
little general what what do you mean
making BNN he is like a star allegedly
in in a film that will be directed by
Rick family would you remember Rick from
Eva yeah I did dope and almost did the
flash yeah and then ran screaming from
the flash yeah and nobody yet has run up
to the flash to make a flash did they
say what this generic superhero movie is
details are the part of being kept under
wraps says the news report from The
Hollywood Reporter but it's being
described as a new type of vigilante
superhero story
like John wick in a cape I'm hoping if
it's that then I mean John wick is a new
kind of superhero story right then and
there
yep I don't know I mean look I'm all for
it everyone should make whatever they
want to make but that's a crowded game
right now making a superhero anything
and if you're not entering that game
with IP that people already know you're
kind of working uphill no I'm not
discouraging anybody like new ideas are
needed it all the time but right now
we're in this Golden Age of like every
hero you grew up
with is now represented on screen I
would not want to be taking a comic-book
movie to marketplace these days unless I
contain one it could say I'm one of the
big two characters characters from the
big - except that his Netflix which is
swallowing content and like a whale and
krill yeah that's that's a funny Nemo
joke for you guys okay in case you're
not rolling with the deep cut kids
movies they are making 700 new TV shows
next year they're making or acquiring
between eighty and a hundred new movies
then of a Mars want to do what do you
guys want anything [ __ ] it weird we're
doing a can of Reeves vigilante movie
superhero nobody's over that where
they're doing it and that's yeah
they got along the content on the model
than Jessica Jones billboards go up so
that must be coming back very soon and
you a Luke Cage teaser drop today did it
it did season two is June 22nd oh [ __ ]
yeah very very soon
Luke Cage season 1 was amazing yeah I
look forward to the 22 seconds they
showed looked amazing it's a wait what
is coming up now we're in March so the
next superhero movie is what next one is
Avengers yeah Avengers and then what
there's a Star Wars movie right solo and
then what's the other one Ant Man in the
wall and then Deadpool - and Deadpool -
Incredibles - what a time to be alive
yes it is it really is every time is a
time to be a live Kevin so much to live
for
yeah good point alright so much to look
forward to alright that's all the news
we got that's almost went to the movies
know what I did I went to go see red
Sparrow
oh [ __ ] is it movie review Tom it can be
if you'd like it - ladies gentlemen grab
your socks and hose and Bowl mark
Bernardin's gonna remove
review a movie do tell
is it Black Widow the movie if that is
black where the movie then we are very
sad about Black Widow the movie oh
because there's not a lot of black widow
in there's not a lot of punching there's
a lot of like I am a [ __ ] because I
went to [ __ ] college school movie
that's a thing in Russia everything is a
thing school [ __ ] you yeah I mean she
plays a prima ballerina in the Bolshoi
Ballet yeah gets not quite so
accidentally snapped in her knee strike
that reverse it and and given that she's
no longer used to the state her uncle is
a high-ranking member of the SVR which
is like the KGB is better looking uncle
and says hey wouldn't you like to be a
[ __ ] as you do as you do he says it
nicer than that but he's like come to
this Academy that we have in the middle
of them and the Snowy nowhere well we
will teach you how to use your feminine
and a handsome wiles to seduce people
and get secrets out of them and then
bring that secret [ __ ] back to the state
the state being Russia because you know
that's how it goes and so she turns out
she's like the worst seducer of people
in this movie different lords yeah
that's really acting because she's all
they ever say about her in the news is
she's so [ __ ] charming oh my god
she's charming she farts and it's cute
yeah they love her she could do no
[ __ ] wrong now except for actually
seduce anybody in this movie really
which she never tries to do I guess cuz
if you look like that you don't have to
but yeah it's this weird like kind of
Cold War ish movie that doesn't have any
real thrills to it it has it it feels
like it wants to be no way out remember
that movie yes [ __ ] I love that movie
with exhauster and Sean Young yes gene
Hackman that was a [ __ ] movie that was
that movie's amazing and it builds to
this point where if you've never seen it
spoilers awesome she had happens more
spoilers Kevin Costner's a Russian sorry
I spoiled it that's a deep [ __ ]
spoiler
but I kept on thinking while I'm sitting
through red Sparrow I wish this was
atomic blonde which I also didn't love
because it was what it's totally
watchable bless you yes watchable but my
is visually engaging yeah but like like
one step too clever for its own good or
so no you think you're a better movie
than this I just want to say Sharlene
just punch people in the face a lot
could you imagine a fourth filmmaker was
I did think it was more clever than that
mark barnard look at my color theory I
know but what what's happening so yeah I
mean it's it's it was not a bad time at
the movies and if you've ever wanted to
see Jennifer Lawrence naked you'll see
her naked a lot in this movie what
happens I think it was the all of my
naked pictures leaked on the internet so
why not so I'm just saying I'm not a big
Laura I like her and stuff but I'm not
like I gotta go [ __ ] and see it right
away she is a wonderful actress but she
doesn't wind up doing a lot of stuff
that I'm necessarily it doesn't it's not
doesn't cross my Venn diagram I wasn't a
hunger person obviously hunger is not a
game didn't appeal to me at all he
didn't build you but I recognized like
she got full-blown towns crazy a crazy
talented actress but that movie had
never really called to me yeah I went
because I was hoping was Black Widow and
if we do get a black widow movie at
least we know it'll be more fun than red
Sparrow was who's the other who's the
guy in the movie joel edgerton oh he's
good did you see the gift I never did
see the game wrote it and he's in it I
don't know if he directed he might have
done that too but [ __ ] that's a good
move yeah yeah it's it's not as up
there's no way out but it's got twists
and turns it's awesome well thought out
there it is [ __ ] red Sparrow you know
what else I saw what black man threw for
the fourth time yo fourth [ __ ] time
what [ __ ] giant big and I'd been with
you but some of us had heart episodes
Wow [ __ ] where'd you see this done I
went to the the theater in Koreatown the
cgv blah blah blah blah blah with a
screen xjx screen x4 TX is downtown
downtown which was kind of Awesome like
I didn't know what to expect going in
other than I saw the trailer I kind of
do it on the screen ex experienced the
street experience
new theater and it's you know you're
familiar with those right and so they
project the movie on the one wall yeah
but every like eight or nine minutes
there's a sequence where it's usually a
computer-generated scenery thing or
they're flying into a condo or they're
in an underground railroad fighting
about [ __ ] and then suddenly the walls
come alive with images suddenly it's
like they've extended the picture so
you're kind of surrounded by the movie
and it's all real information it's not
like oh no it's it's green because when
the jungle is who we just like leaves
and [ __ ] like no it's actually
information digital content that you
wouldn't see unless you were a version
of the movie that like ILM or which of
the 98 effects house has worked on black
black panther gave them more information
to put on the on the panels of the
screen and it's kind of amazing its kind
of immersive in a way that I didn't
expect it to be and then it stops and
they go back to dialogue and [ __ ] but
there's a gray busan car chase and
suddenly you're in the middle of [ __ ]
busan and shits whizzing by you and you
saw more in the korean car chase yeah
what did you see
streets street lamps roads I mean like
there's a whole nother movie going on
here like was Iron Man there yeah like
that's where they put the ulysses klaw
SoundCloud link like his mixtape is
coming in off the left all right let me
get a good time in that movie [ __ ] you
seem to be enjoying alright so once
again black panther well worth saying
yes i think you know i might go for five
i don't know we'll see
i am paying full [ __ ] boat for that
it'll single-handedly save the movie
industry i will it'll they'll be
counting down like man we're almost at a
billion we just gotta get like eleven
more dollars they're gonna hit it easily
aren't they hey mark when again they're
getting that sweet bernard and money oh
yeah alright man is that it that is all
the news that it's fit to print ladies
and gentlemen when we're done talking
about the news very special thing
happens here on j and sub [ __ ] from one
god
hey man I just had a [ __ ] heart
attack
very special thing happens here on fat
man on Batman we open up the floor to
questions now you can throw your hands
in the air wave them like just don't
care JC is gonna pick you out but rather
than come to you are we bringing into a
specific place we got new camera
hangings this year that's the spot here
so there's a camera that's beaded on
that beautiful so this time around on
fat man I'm Batman we've got some two
audience cameras no never mind we've got
yeah I saw somebody show me a [ __ ]
grid nose like holy [ __ ] this looks pro
so as always JC is gonna go pick you out
and then he'll bring you over that spot
you can ask the question so the folks at
home can see as well now when yeah when
you ask a question of course oh god we
got gifts to give out man folks at 4dx
have given us tickets to give out as
have the good folks at the Ripley's
Believe It or Not museum man so if you
ask a question you'll receive two
tickets to both two tickets to this it
looks like four tickets to Ripley's is
that right where should we break them up
and do two per okay we can if you want
to keep answering questions very true
stop singing so so the 40x experience if
you've never seen a movie in 40x ladies
and gentlemen you owe it to yourself to
do it man it snows in the movie theater
if it's snowing on the screen if a
motorcycle go screeching pastor you
smell burnt [ __ ] rubber your chair
moves if you're watching the crawl on a
Star Wars movie your chair goes back as
the crawl goes up and stuff it's a
wonderful experience we got two free
tickets for you thanks to the good folks
at 40x and our good friend Brett deke
and give it up for deacon man good and
our good friends at Ripley's Believe It
or Not auditorium I still called that
it's a wonderful place to go see [ __ ] I
took the kid there all the time when we
first moved to Hollywood when she was a
youngster so I look at those tickets and
fills me with a happy childhood memories
well her childhood not mine so we're
going to now go into the question mode
period we only
this you can't just ask anything cuz
this is a pretty sweet swag you got to
ask a question that is relevant to both
of us you can't just you know like
what's it like on the other side like my
mom asked me like that keep it about
this show and also you know it's got to
be good for both of us and stuff like
that so we do get a bit shitty and a bit
judgey at this point of the show if you
ask something that's been asked before
what not we will not give you the
[ __ ] tickets so just know that it's
you gotta come up with some good [ __ ]
you've already picked somebody sir yeah
although right before we start Jason
here made that for you based on one of
your tweets oh my god that is beautiful
so what do we say to the god of death
not today that is [ __ ] gorgeous thank
you [ __ ] all right now we got questions
okay god that's beautiful
[ __ ] framing that [ __ ] that's drusen
level awesome right there that's the
kind of life I have like if you walk
around my house is framed drawings of me
and [ __ ] to museum everywhere alright
man how are you hi Kevin hi oh hi mark
how are you hello hey so I do have a
question for both you guys but I do want
to say briefly I wait I was here last
Thursday when you guys had the the
during the week show and I just want to
say it's a privilege to actually be here
and get to ask you a question personally
Kevin I read the news on Monday and I
was I was really broken up and I'm glad
to see you're back on your feet awesome
alright guys so my question is it's
regarding Black Panther we all had the
privilege of seeing Black Panthers movie
some of us four times and and we all
know that he's more than capable of
carrying his own movie but as you guys
kind of touched on before it's
inevitable that coming with the New
Avengers affinity war movie that a big
characters are gonna die if they're
smart it's gonna probably be Captain
America
you think so I really think so I mean
they're following the Brubaker
series everybody in my they live alone
and thinking it's gonna be Tony Stark
why can't it be both Oh it'd be enough
to lose [ __ ] both man maybe one per
movie a Canada man won't lose both of
them in the first I mean if they go with
the current continuity they can lose
Robert Downey and then he could just
come back his AI for the next it's a
paycheck he's basically podcasting at
that point he can literally record with
his dick out if he wanted ask Neil
Gaiman that's how we go so the question
is uh I'm banking that uh Captain
America is gonna die it's gonna leave a
gaping hole for the next Avengers team
yes I I kind of know my answer to this
question already but my question to you
guys now is um is black panther right
person to lead the New Avengers team and
yes or no and why I'll go first because
you'll have a way better answer than me
yes because he's the most profitable
right now money talks and yes I think of
course absolutely be a no-brainer at
this point make him the head of the the
new version of the team if it was me I
would make Black Widow the leader of the
team because there's the part of me that
remembers reading the x-men back in the
day when storm lost her powers and then
had to fight Cyclops for the leadership
of the x-men and one and the reason why
is because she was willing to do more
and go further like the idea of a non
powered person leading a powered phalanx
of super [ __ ] people she understands
the responsibilities of it more than say
Thor does you know like I think that
there's there's some really wonderful
dramatic opportunities if if you put it
in in Natasha's hands as much as I love
some T'Challa - you know - Charlie be
crazy I I would I I feel like yeah Black
Widow we written mine to do and it is
manifestly not also unfair to tax the
king of another country to be like hey
can you also be the
engines he's like I got a whole country
I've got protecting vibranium here solve
your own [ __ ] problems
he's a kid but we got jackets okay where
do you want to fight at an airport
other than that I'm done thank you guys
very much
excellent job you want some tickets give
it up for him ladies John that's great
class right
take one and one meanwhile JC where we
going to next all right here we go
hey guys how's it going
Kevin I just want to say thank you so
much for being here it's really great to
I mean like it's really great to be able
to see you again after the whole word
yeah I mean I was I was at the show on
Sunday
you were there yeah well yeah the second
show and they came out told us you
didn't get to see a show
honestly I was thinking to you not you
personally but you in the second show
that kept me from going to the hospital
for as long as I was because I was like
I don't want to let the people down like
[ __ ] I got another show to do they
told me when I finished the first show
they're like you were only supposed to
do an hour into two hours so we have our
entire [ __ ] special the next show is
just gravy and stuff so the whole time I
was like yeah even though it's gravy
they're all here they're lined up and
like you know it's [ __ ] two hours
it's nothing and then I started to feel
bad I mean I was just there was a point
where I was like well I don't know we
might have to cancel the show and that
was when they wheeled me into the
emergency room yeah so at that point I
felt a little bit bad when they took me
out the back I waved to some cast I
don't know if they were for the next
show or the previous show when they took
me into the ambulance I'm glad you did
cancel because you know now you get to
be here so yeah but it was gonna be a
killer show yeah you know you're right
I'm here that matters my question is
since mark since you just did the well
the question for both of you but since
you just did the Black Panther
roundtable I was wondering like I just
kind of had this idea in my head when uh
infinity war comes out how would you
guys feel like if you guys got like all
of the SModcast guys like Ralph and Andy
and Jay and like did another round table
for like infinity war and like called it
something catchy like this um Avengers
or something
like marking the whities yeah I didn't
think about that but you know one organ
even more white guy cracker barrel of
fun because I love a good idea lot of us
who do podcast for smart guys are
obviously big genre fans so yeah that is
a [ __ ] smart take I would totally do
that
how did your round table go for those
that weren't paying attention I think it
went pretty well but I can never tell
because I never watched them I have a
thing where I don't like to look at
myself or listen to myself because it's
uncannily awful so but I feel like the
energy in the room was pretty cool I
think that that Evan particularly told
the story about how Evan Narcisse writes
rise of the Black Panther the comic book
for Marvel and he was talking about how
he and his dad have been estranged for
almost 20 25 years like they just they
didn't speak there's a bad phony on the
family I think his mother had moved on
and found somebody else and so he'd
never really had any contact with his
dad
until one day like he was having a
signing at Midtown comics and his dad
shows up because his dad who he hasn't
spoken to in any real way in almost two
decades got word that he was writing a
Black Panther comic book and showed up
at a comic book store where he was at to
get it signed by his son
that's pretty moving story and just the
idea that this character that this
moment in time made it possible for him
to reconnect that I mean it's and it's a
movie that's about tradition it's about
heritage it's about legacy it's my
lineage it's about fathers and sons it's
it's about all these things it's about
remembering your history and not
forgetting it and holding on to it for
this movie in this character to bring
his history together in a way you know
we were all just trying not to [ __ ]
cries like you haven't [ __ ] we
were not prepared to be crying about
Black Panther today and yet here we are
and I think that that what around Conda
to weep Conda hell yes but I think that
that in many ways that's what this movie
has done for a lot of people is just to
offer this this bonding agent for both
of themselves for the community for
their families and and it's not just a
black thing it's not just an
african-american thing I think it's like
literally it's a movie that's about
remembering who you are and where you're
from and even if who you are where
you're from isn't as awesome as makanda
it all kind of has value and so yeah I'm
super glad we did that and it was a lot
of fun and it looks like we'll do it
again with Mark and the Whitey's
when Avengers happens great job you give
him a give it up ladies Jim he wins the
parking tickets whichever you like one
pile only choose wisely take us there JC
all right here we go
how you doing guys how are you so while
you were recovering I started looking up
a bunch of YouTube stuff and I found a
dinner for five the Jon Favreau show
yeah and I saw your show with Jason Lee
JJ Abrams Mark Hamill and Stan Lee of
course yes and so my question is for you
guys if you can invite four people no
matter if they're dead alive fictional
and non-fictional
who would it be yeah well I think mine
that was my list back of the day but
that was 2001 but I can go deeper I can
go into the dead let's see my dad cuz
what the [ __ ] if I'm raising the dead I
might be like hey man how are you Batman
in full costume
[Laughter]
where's the butter not the badass like
that the real Batman let's see who else
would I pick [ __ ] mm-hmm I mean the old
me would say Jesus but all right Jesus
just to be like are you real
yes I am I [ __ ] change my ways
instantly and [ __ ] you know yeah I am
real and I hate Dogma you won't ever run
out of fish and or bread that's true man
we can eat kind of pescetarian and then
one more slot Abraham Lincoln
he seems like a [ __ ] fun guy yeah got
some [ __ ] we could talk to him about
lived through history plus he got killed
to be like what'd it feel like to get
shot in the head and if he was like not
that bad that'd take another fear of
mine right now that's my list how about
you Mitchell Isaiah 5 I thought I was
the right clothes for Quincy Jones
especially lately oh well yes who
[ __ ] knew that Marlon Brando and
Richard Pryor bust around we would have
never have known that weren't enough for
the great Quincy job dear God
get together drinking that man and
everything comes forward Quincy Jones
Richard Pryor okay Mel Brooks Wow Jim
Henson oh nice your let's got applause
man that makes Batman well the show you
know anyway great question man give it
up for him you get some tickets ladies
Johnny one
cigarette please take one of it no not
both oh I thought it was no one one out
then take the 40 X I thought we were
giving away both no oh I thought it was
you get tickets and tickets I'm gonna
stretch this man I see they'll be more
all right where are we going next JC we
got a guy coming from the far side of
the room okay oh all the way load the
next one in the chamber
yeah there you go Hey
so we'll be in question about you is
with Batgirl losing the director who
would be your jean director and plot
point for the film did we talk about
that last time I think we did we talked
about the giass of it all yes because we
during the day show yes okay with
Batgirl losing director who would I like
to see take over Batgirl um let's see
Lexi Alexander I'm always plugging for I
thought she did a [ __ ] amazing job
with that Punisher movie and on script
who would I like to see on script mm-hmm
I mean honestly and it's not gonna be
popular answer in world of movies but
deserves a shot cuz she'd been telling
Batgirl stories for a long time Gail
Simone I'd love to see her write a
[ __ ] script her write a script Lexi
Alexander dress what about you sir uh I
think I would like Michelle Maclaren to
direct TV Thrones Breaking Bad all of
the things that are awesome yeah and to
write it
[Music]
Lena wife who that Lena wife is the the
writer creator of the shy on Showtime
she was also in master of none she is
awesome and wonderful and the most
impressive lesbian you'll ever meet
well I've met some impressive lesbians
that bar is very high but yeah like I
think she's she's just nerdy enough but
also knows how to make the [ __ ]
clocks go so yeah that would that would
be my twofer that series experienced if
I can't if I can't have Lexie directing
it then fine I like it there's your
answer you get some tickets give it up
for him ladies and gentlemen meanwhile
what you got next JC hello hello why
hello how are you I'm well how are you
so good I was able you heard but I never
mind I was that I was I was actually
there and I got to see the show so how
was it was great thank you
yeah but you're gonna Whittle it down I
think you should do the full two hours
or whatever it was we we did it's gotta
be it's got a home and it has to be 60
to 75 minutes so I just did two cuts
this morning one of a 60-minute version
one of a 75-minute version both are very
very funny and at the end of the day if
you leave them wanting more that's not
necessarily a bad thing don't wanna I've
thought about believe me I was like I'm
gonna put the whole [ __ ] two hours up
there well had a nice arc and it was
like people might be like you know an
hour would have been enough I'm glad
you're alive but come on
well it was great so few things right it
worked out for air man oh I'm gonna go
look at the footage and see if I could
see your face front row like the very
left like literally the very left if
you're facing the crowd the left but I
was front row you looked a little
teary-eyed during the standing ovation
so I don't know if that was a mix of
emotion but also maybe the sickness okay
I hope this question isn't too too much
of a downer but the in memoriam section
of the Oscars I know left a lot of folks
off the list and I think this
unfortunate I'm subscribed to the Ralph
report and he's been chatting about this
a lot so I know Adam West's and Michael
parts and some folks like that I
personally would have put I mean Michael
Park seems like a no-brainer and Michael
Park seems like a no-brainer and my
question and I'll give you my answer
before I ask the question is Michael
parks in red state would be a nice piece
to show and his in memoriam I'm curious
if there's any people that you felt were
left off and if there were what clip you
might play if you were choosing their
clip last year a friend of mine passed
away and I thought he'd be in the in
memoriam it he didn't make it and then I
was kind of holding out stupid hope that
he might be in this year but as you said
they didn't put Adam West in it Adam
West was in the legit movies and they
didn't put Michael parks in it Michael
parks was in legit movies and stuff so
at the end of the day Jim Jack's was a
producer on Mallrats he produced
tombstone Dazed and Confused all the
mummy movies with Brendan Fraser this
guy gave his whole life to the [ __ ]
movie business and stuff and aggregated
to his dream job didn't come from that
world was raised the son of an army he
was an army brat so he'd call his dad
the the general or the major he his
parents he loved movies as a kid but his
parents were like you know you're gonna
be an engineer and so he did what he was
told then he went to school and became
an engineer and then he would spend all
of his free time at the movie theaters
just [ __ ] love movies so we'd go to
this theater called the circle theater
that was run by these two brothers and
he would tell them after the movies like
he was always there every week multiple
days a week and he would tell them there
are these movies I read about you should
get them to come to this theater and
stuff and so one day they were like do
you want to work here you seem to know a
lot about movies so you could be our
programmer and so he came in and started
programming the circle theater and did
that for a long time and movies he
picked earned for that little theater
and so the brothers who owned the
theater told them one day they were like
why don't we put out a movie like we're
exhibitors we could distribute so why
don't you go find a movie at the
American film market so Jim said okay
and he got on a plane an engineer
somebody who was not from the movie
business at all and [ __ ]
just got one step closer to his [ __ ]
dream aggregated to his dream job of
being in the movies and never upset
anybody else's applecart to do it a lot
of us who want to do [ __ ] in life it's
like follow me come hell or high water
I'm going at my way this [ __ ]
did as told
but then quietly bit by bit just kind of
aggregated toward his dream job so he
goes out to the American film market to
look for
to bring back to the circle theater that
they could distribute to other theaters
call their own
comes back with a movie he tells the
brothers I found this movie it's getting
very good praise I loved it never seen
anything like it but it reminds me of
older movies very film the warts by
these two young brothers who've never
made a movie before
it's called Blood Simple and so the
circle theater the circle productions
picked up Blood Simple the Coen brothers
first movie and put it out there in the
world and they did very well by it and
so they told Jim the like as a reward
like you got to work with these guys
again we get another movie out of them
so oversee their next movie and that
movie was raising Arizona and with that
God bless you as a producer executive
producer I'm raising Arizona Jim Jack's
entered his dream he did what he was
supposed to and did was parents told him
and [ __ ] and did the work and went to
college got a job that he didn't want
and [ __ ] but without upsetting anybody
else's life aggregated to his [ __ ]
dream job and once he got in the door
all he did was [ __ ] make movies the
dude legit cared about it he cared about
you cared about everybody in this
[ __ ] room though he never met you
because he always thought about what you
wanted and wanted to show you something
[ __ ] beautiful he made movies that
none of us will ever forget [ __ ] like
dazed confused he produced Mallrats for
me so I'll never forget him for that and
stuff he's got a long list of movies
that were commercially successful as
well and he passed away two years ago
rather suddenly at a heart attack on a
treadmill and [ __ ] died nobody was
there to save him and stuff so Jim went
so I thought he would be in the last
year's in memoriam because those mommy
movies made some loot and [ __ ] like that
but he didn't make it and then I thought
alright maybe it was too soon it just
happened he'll show up this year but he
didn't show up so if I would if I could
on or anybody bless you I would honor
Jim Jack's is like all the movies that a
bunch of filmmakers love and a bunch of
audience love a bunch of movies that
made people go I want to be a movie
maker and [ __ ] he made like he was
behind he was the guy behind those
movies and the clip I would show what
would what would be Jack's
I mean I'd be tempted to show something
from all eras cuz that mean I'd get on
the Oscars too but what would really
stand for
Jax would like honestly honestly like
it's crazy to say but those mummy movies
with Brendan Fraser were his passion
project like from matam I met him when
we met him at the closing word ceremony
at Sundance 1994 met him at the at the
bar and stuff I was introduced by our
friend John Pierce he goes this is Jim
Jackson said Jim Jax I know you you
produced Dazed and Confused
he said yeah he's gone I liked your
movie I almost bought it but Miramax
bought it out from under me he's gone I
said you liked he goes yeah I would have
I would have remade it though at
Universal and I would have made it in
color and I would have let you keep
about 80% of the movie and I was like
80% what would I've had to have lost and
he goes nobody [ __ ] a dead guy in a
universal will we I was like well I'm
glad it went the other way and stuff and
he started talking again you got any
other ideas and I said um I said yeah I
got a movie I wanna make called Mallrats
which I didn't it was just an idea in my
head and he goes Mallrats what's that I
said it's like clerks but in a mall and
he goes you're good they're gonna be
flown out to Los Angeles to meet with
Disney because Miramax was owned by
Disney in those days he's like you'll
probably meet with the Hollywood
Pictures people and stuff they do this
for all the Sundance kids they go to the
studio you meet them they fly out he's
gone tell him whatever you want but
don't tell them mall rats save that and
bring that to Universal that's okay and
so I I went like two months later sure
enough he was right Disney flew us out
to Los Angeles and we talked met with
all the studios and [ __ ] and they're
like we like your movie what do you want
to do and I was I told them what I
wanted to do but nobody was interested
they pitched me a bunch of [ __ ]
movies they wanted me to do and stuff
but Jim Jack's I held onto the mall rats
pitch and took it to Universal and I
told them I was like you know Disney
flew me out here I feel kind of bad
about that he goes [ __ ] them they got
all the money
so ever since I known him from 1994
forward man he was always talking about
the mummy and never call them the mummy
you always called him him hotep and
stuff he was just like oh one day I'm
gonna make that Imhotep movie and I was
like you should probably call it the
[ __ ] mummy he's like I will but in my
heart he'll be in hotel and he built
that franchise from the ground up and he
was the guy that believed in the rock
you like bringing in Dwayne the rock
Johnson he was a big fan of his and also
believed in his like he's got a huge
following in the world of wrestling he's
charming I'm sure he could be in movies
as well so I guess I would have to show
a clip from from the mummy because I do
believe without Jim that particular
version that incarnation I pulley
acknowledged the mummy had existed in
the universal film history but he was
the guy who kept tub-thumping for them
if Jim jacks was still alive today the
dark universe would be up and running
and he would be the guy running it
because he was the guy that loved those
Universal Monsters it captured his
imagination as a child when I went to
his funeral his brother gave a eulogy
and stuff and he talked about when they
were kids
like Jim was a little older than him
they would go to the movies like he'd
take his little brother the movies and
they'd watched the movies and then after
the movies they would follow adults that
were talking about the movie to wherever
they went so if they went to the nearby
diner they would get a booth right
behind those adults and listen to what
they said about the movie and the whole
time Jim would say to his little brother
he didn't understand it at all you know
and break it down this is what the
movies about Jim was the internet before
the internet existed in [ __ ] so this was
a guy who loved movies and then like
dreamed of telling stories that like
captured his imagination as a kid for a
new generation and he did that with the
mummy movie so I would say Jim Jack's
with a mummy clip did he love the
Stanley Brody scene as well - which one
the Stanley Brody scene from all rats
wasn't that one of his favorites around
America Petey got us Stanley I'd written
the first draft of Mallrats it wasn't
Stanley I just wrote like a comics guru
like it's kind of like the Wolfman Jack
character
American Graffiti so he was not named it
was San Lee but I didn't use Stan Lee's
name at all he was the most prominent
figures in the world of comics and so
when Jim Jack's read the script he goes
was this one character man at Brody's
impressed by I was like oh he's like
kind of like Stan Lee I guess and he's
our version of Stan Lee because watch is
writing for Stan Lee and I was like I
don't know Stan Lee and he goes well I
do and that's when I was like Hollywood
is good like all these [ __ ] know each
other and [ __ ] so he goes I'll ask him
if he wants to do it he's going if I
know Stan he'll want to do it he's a big
ham and he asked Stan and Stan was like
yeah absolutely so I wrote the scene and
sent it to Jim and then Jim Y faxed it
to Jim and then Jim faxed it to stand in
the first reaction that standed at
apparently to the pages as the story
goes is I would never say this [ __ ] but
Jim Jackson's like he's an up-and-coming
filmmaker trust me it's a good idea and
so Stan trusted Jim because they were
friends because Jim wanted to make
Marvel movies he was a big comic book
fan and stuff so it all worked out
because of Jim Jack's man so yeah he
sees tied in with my story in a big bad
way you
[Laughter]
okay well there's there's two people one
of which I'm sure I didn't see in the in
memoriam section the other one
I can't believe was it included yes
Bernie Casey that's right Bernie Casey
wasn't the Bernie Casey who was my felix
leiter in the James Bond you never say
never again yeah and was also in a bunch
of other [ __ ] that damn sure you have
seen he's like he was named Jefferson
what in Revenge of the Nerds he was the
head of the lambdas oh that's right the
lamda house I always think of him as the
guy who trained Aykroyd and Chevy Chase
and spies like us yes he was that guy
and I'm I maybe I've got the timeline
wrong but I don't think I do I didn't
see Bill Paxton in the in memoriam or
was he there and I missed it he was not
in the in memoriam but maybe he died
last year did he so he made the Oscars
last she made the Oscars last year he
didn't make the Oscars last year and he
didn't make it this year so the policy
is if they miss you they don't catch up
the next year again well that's [ __ ]
up I know he died right before the
Oscars last year is that last year
Jennifer Aniston talked about last year
Jennifer Aniston talked about him but he
didn't make the in the death montage
gotcha
but no forever live in our hearts but
you're right that was a glaring omission
yeah so Bernie Casey's my answer I do
not have a 12-minute story about Bernie
Casey I think he was awesome he was
reliably cool in the way that some
actors were just you could put him in
something he would make it a little bit
better and I think his Jefferson Davis I
think his name was in intervention than
Eric's and that would be the clip come
on say one more thing okay you guys
don't owe us anything that being said
you still owe us a dark night commentary
so we're gonna hold you to it we just so
we'll do we'll save it for another
holiday thank you so much guys pleasure
man give it up
we want some tickets yes we we've got
the bar wired now that we could do it
here in front of an audience attractive
to people what do you mean again we
could put a TV in here and put TVs up if
people would want to come and watch you
talk about that man as opposed to every
other comic book find me a man
so guys hey you know I'm keep it short
I'm glad to hear glad you're alive glad
we all get to see you of course
or I could see you too but you know I
just don't want to repeat what everybody
else says but I do feel the same way so
thank you very much yes so I saw the saw
new ready player one trailer and the
thing that stood out most to me was oh
snap it's the RX 79 mobile suit gundam I
love that saw the Akira bike
so I've been thinking with the new Death
Note series that came in on Netflix you
had ghosts on the shell come out last
year you have a leader coming out this
year it seems like Hollywood is
definitely more into taking chances with
anime you know and manga adaptations you
know ghosts in the show it's kind of
wack you know you know visually look
great but it's kind of wack my whole
thing is like my question to you guys
both is what is it gonna take for you
know what is what is it going to take
for lightning to strike kind of with
with that particular you know genre if
you will is it gonna have to be the
right adaptation or is it gonna have to
be the right set of circumstances actors
involved crew etc I bet you it's got to
be something akin to something that a
lot of people recognize so there's
immediately a fan base for it which was
the case with the Black Panther bless
you Marvel had built up an amazing fan
base Plus just people who had wanted to
see that character since he was in comic
book since they were kids
so maybe it needs to be something like
Akira
were the last airbender but really done
correctly for the people that love that
series not the M night Shyamalan version
itself and not taking anything away from
him as a filmmaker but clearly there was
a more true to the series version of
that movie that could have been done so
if you take some IP like that that
people know like oh [ __ ] and then you
just make it palatable for everybody and
why couldn't they have their own version
so to speak why can't anime have their
Black Panthers so to speak or manga but
it would have to be I don't it would
have to be something that like people
can get their heads around a little bit
and I know last airbender doesn't really
count
Akira probably is that is the one that
like people are familiar with but don't
really know and if you did a killer
version of that with a cast that looked
like the cast in the comic books and the
original material it could pan out huge
that's a story that I always felt was
impenetrable for me though I've seen
that cartoon so many times and still to
this day I'm like I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened it's beautiful its
sumptuous but I've never understood it
maybe a movie I would understand yeah
yeah I mean I think that that you're
right it needs that that cultural moment
where it feels as if everything is
swirling in in in a magnetic kind of way
the same way Marvel again did all the
heavy lifting and got us to Black
Panther and and for as long as that
characters been around like it's still
even if every fan of that book showed up
you need a lot more of them to get to a
billion dollars that's true I feel like
for me I would love to see a Voltron
movie yeah like I feel like the mixture
of [ __ ] awesome lions and and Mecca
and all of that [ __ ] like that you get
the kaiju stuff you get the transformer
stuff you the things that people already
seem to like all in one and then if you
cast it right and you do it right and
you get like Jon Chu to directed or you
get you know [ __ ] James Wan to direct
it and then you build the right cast
around that then then yeah like it
becomes irresistible and I think that
that's what these things need to be to
the point where like yeah we don't have
to have Scarlett Johansson and this for
it to be irresistible it is just Oh
god we have five [ __ ] lions forming a
giant robot with a flaming sword that's
shopping things to pieces like why don't
we have that that of our Blazers I would
vote for Star Blazers I was a big fan of
that as a kid does that still count yeah
it's old school I'll allow it
thank for the judge hey great question
give it up for me won some tickets come
grab your ticket
whichever one you want man do you
remember the theme to Star Blazers no
bet you have the word Star Blazers in it
though it did what about Mack Ross well
what what Matt cross all right no yes
makes stuff killing it you know anyway
sorry how are you good how are you great
to see both you guys that's kind of
relates to you know the idea of what he
was saying about you know anime movies
and properties that that we haven't seen
yet that we'd like to see you guys as
writers and as a filmmaker as well and
hopefully maybe one day you might sit in
the director's chair
oh nice oon what is there a comic book
character or franchise that we haven't
seen yet from you know doesn't have to
be Marvel doesn't have to be DC it could
be dynamite it could be image whatever
that you would want to write that you
would want to talk about that that you
want to write that you would want to
direct or just that you want to see on
screen that seems pretty far out there
but now with the prolific amount of
comic book movies maybe it could happen
I say this every time I love DC Comics
as a character called the question Oh
everything either as a movie or as a
series would be totally fun to see and
it's easy to pull off at this point like
we're moving people's features digitally
even if they just wanted to do that as a
constant effect shot me a little pricier
but they could easily make something as
well to cover somebody's face I still
like that notion I I'd back that a
hundred percent you yeah I feel like
I've talked about before but it still
holds I said you guys part get asked
this a lot yeah no it's cool I love
talking about lone wolf and cub it's one
of my favorite comic books ever
and you know this vast sweeping samurai
Depok that's told over 22 volumes of
manga at some 4,000 pages of content to
adapt and it's you know Game of Thrones
+ samurais and [ __ ] but I think I would
also I feel like we could get to a world
and we're not that far from it where you
get Lobo on screen in a real way
very yeah that seems more plausible than
ever now yeah I mean you don't have to
pivot that far from Deadpool to get you
know and whatever [ __ ] James one
Aquaman is gonna be like it feels as if
there's absolutely a path that leads you
there and if they are no longer
hell-bent on only got a build to just
sleek - and instead they're like we can
do [ __ ] anything because nothing's
working so hey then I feel like you can
actually get a Lobo movie and it could
just be balls-out crazy and and run with
it and stand alone and it doesn't have
to hook into some universe or make sense
no I mean maybe maybe he's got a he's
got a Lantern ring around a necklace and
that's all we ever see of the lanterns
that's all we ever see of the DC
Universe just he killed the [ __ ]
Lantern watts and keeps it keeps her
ring as a trophy that's [ __ ] awesome
that's a great question give it up for
him you get some tickets where are we
going next how are you hey hi glad we're
all here doing this so just want to
preface this by saying that I absolutely
loved Black Panther but one of my
frustrations with the movie really I do
is the fact that we get to see so little
of everyday wakandan life in certain
aspects of what content culture like for
me personally the fact that we never get
to see King to chacas funeral is kind of
huge for me didn't you pitch a version
last time you were like there's a world
where that was the opening scene yeah
that that because - Chaka dies off
screen fundamentally for this movie and
because T'Challa zark is very kind of
horizontally flat like ease I'm King
Kings awesome oh [ __ ] I got into a
mission I failed at it what oh my god
I'm not King I am King again like it's
it's all writing kind of here but if you
build a narrative where he's not
King until the very end until like his
coronation is supposed to be ends up
being the kill manga fight and kill
Munger takes the crown so so start with
a funeral see all of Wakanda see the
beauty in the majesty of everything and
you can still introduce in Bakke you can
still introduce all of the various
tribes but instead you're celebrating
the old and then giving him a rise so
that he's coordinated by the end of the
movie and said the beginning of the
movie but that's just me
well the other thing too is that we
never get to see what what Condon money
looks like and I was really curious to
see if they were gonna have like a
coming to America like and I was just
wondering if maybe there was an aspect
of wakandan life that maybe you were
super curious about maybe frustrated
that they didn't get a chance to really
show that in the movie great [ __ ]
question naturally I want to know how
wakandans [ __ ]
and Disney wouldn't show us know let me
think did I they never freeze good and
pull I don't let me see I mean look I'm
health hella forgiving because it's the
first time and they got a lot of
information to to get across and tell us
the story and and so I for I was
honestly surprised we saw as much of
what Conda as we did based on like the
heavy lifting they had to do it looks
like we're going back there for the next
Avengers movies it seems like the lot of
its taking place there but no it never
honestly I'm not that imaginative as a
movie audience member well I'm like oh I
would have liked it if they did this
more when it comes to movies that I that
I really dig and that movie I didn't
feel like was for me missing anything
yeah I mean there's this stuff that that
if this was a TV show you would get a
sense of we don't know if there are any
cities in Wakanda all we've ever told is
Wakanda like clearly there have to be
there's a capital city there's the river
tribe the border tribe all of these
plates have places they live and come
from and what that's like and who are
the other people on the [ __ ]
Parliament to console whatever how does
that dude get the plate in his lip like
yes there's a bunch of [ __ ] that if you
had 10 hours to play with then you could
kind of like all right and where did the
dorm Elijah come from how do you
shoot them how do you train them in the
comics it was also the dorm Ellijay were
prospective wives for the king of
Wakanda and until he was chose one they
also served as as honor guard not that I
feel like that was a good thing to omit
for the movie it's like I know these are
all like these are the women he will
choose from it's not a good look in in
2018 but just the texture of it I mean
you're right it's very servicing because
it has to be because they have so much
to [ __ ] do and and the fact that they
got to do as much as they did is is kind
of remarkable actually like the fact
that we're in Auckland in the past and
present we keep bouncing back and forth
and ancestral plane and kill monger and
what his story is and oh [ __ ] and door
mulashi and casino heists and all this
stuff like it doesn't leave us a lot of
time for like shopping in Wakanda that's
the movie I do what kind of mall rats
yeah no I'm just not as clever like you
two I was very like oh that's good and I
was shocked that we saw as much as we do
I mean more so than any other Marvel
movie boy there was a sense of place and
community their location played a big
role was almost a secondary character
great question you win some tickets come
on up how are you hello hello I came all
the way from Brazil Brazil you get
tickets regardless yeah I actually got
tickets for the Babylon as well then
something happened to you and I actually
called The Improv - is that true they
say yeah yeah yeah he almost died yeah
yeah I figured I'm ok with this one as
well because I thought I was good I
wasn't gonna get anyway any show my my
dad actually recovered from a heart
attack and that's that's not that's not
a toy that's not like that's not
something
[ __ ] around and I'm like well I'm not
just standing in a pond talking yeah but
I'm drinking that'd be bad yeah so yeah
actually I'm very excited to see you
alive and kicking because I'm very
looking forward for the new asylum yeah
I was convalescing I did another draft
of the script and yeah I just keep
tinkering and tinkering and bringing it
down making it tighter
awesome awesome so since the the topic
is reboot if you guys could reboot
anything anything at all what would it
be
go first shoot there's a Disney movie
called Bedknobs and Broomsticks oh
that's awesome
that's the [ __ ] yeah I love this movie
though my heart's big part of my
childhood
yeah a lot of my imagination kind of
comes from and stuff but I and while it
is a brilliant [ __ ] piece of
filmmaking from its era storytelling
shall we say from its era you be a hard
press to get a kid to watch that today
yeah it's just the like if we go to our
tune characters they're literally
two-dimensional and stuff and kids today
are trained for you know three
dimensions that's so I think you could
get away with that movie it's got
everything that's [ __ ] commercial
it's got which is which do very well in
the box office [ __ ] Harry Potter made
a buck or two it's got Nazis which is
fighting knives yeah which is fighting
that and which is fighting Nazis with an
army of the undead that she [ __ ]
raises herself with a [ __ ] spell all
of Emmet's cartoons and like all of it
[ __ ] rock kids that are in jeopardy
World War two
you know so you can get Gary Oldman to
do a cameo as Churchill and like them
from the broomstick from the god I love
them
we bed take us to the Isle of naboombu
and when they go under the water who
would you put in it who didn't happen in
it
let's see while I was in [ __ ] the
hospital Chris Pratt tweeted at me so I
put him in every he's he's excellent
he's excellent
actually we see that version of it man
yeah very charming very very good actor
very funny he's wonderful
absolutely and [ __ ] boy he could pull
it off so yeah I say Bedknobs and
Broomsticks you I will give you one that
can't ever happen oh because the
screenwriter in some fashion retained
the rights and refuses to give it up to
anybody
the last starfighter that's a good one I
love the last what do you mean about
there's never been a remake Spielberg
made a run at it and couldn't get it
Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg made a run
out it couldn't get it they made future
man instead which is basically the last
starfighter
but yeah the the rights holder the dude
who wrote the movie doesn't want anybody
to touch it and Spielberg made a run at
it Spielberg made a run at it and
somebody said no to Spielberg yeah fancy
that and live to tell the story but I
still I mean I love that movie I still
think that movie - fantastic the themes
of that movie are just as relevant today
as they were then really explain I think
the the idea of wanting to be from
someplace else than you are like
realizing I live in a trailer park in
the middle of nowhere and I'm meant for
more than this and given the world we
currently live on the income inequality
has left more people feeling as if I'm
living in a trailer park and I meant for
more than this and the idea that
technology can be the key and the route
and the way in the light out of that and
to [ __ ] go in outer space and destroy
the code on our monitor in the corridor
you know like I feel like there's there
are so many ways to make that both
contemporary without losing any of what
made it awesome in 1984 beautiful answer
man excellent question give it up for me
actually I don't want tickets because
you're going I'm leaving tomorrow oh I'm
going back home tomorrow okay I do want
to picture with you guys the show okay I
guarantee it because I may like be
rushed out of here in an ambulance
that's not gonna happen shows now yeah
will you try to grab one afterwards okay
thanks pleasure give it up for Brazil he
did it thank you
how are you doing all right what kind of
forever this is my first time like he's
like an ambassador here and I'm loving
him so it's really great and very
helpful always now in Batman vs Superman
they kind of had a bunch of different
story arcs but one of the ones that I
really like is the Justice gods amongst
us kind of story arc not sure if you're
familiar with it but if you were to have
armored Superman style and the regime
versus Batman and a resistance who would
do who do you think would join the
regime and who do you think would join
the resistance and why I think Aquaman
joins the resistance and he got mad
sharks lasers
Wonder Woman goes with cow Barry goes
with Bruce was who's the lantern how
yeah how goes with Bruce know how goes
with cow cause Hal and Cal rhyme who
else
I mean are we using their justice league
the current incarnation I would say go
for any of the Justice League
um I got who else would [ __ ] fight
against Superman Oh Ollie Oliver Queen
of course he would join the [ __ ]
resistance I mean he can't wait to
[ __ ] take an arrow shoot it up
Superman's ass where's Jon Jones go oh
the resistance just to be surprising
he's like I have no real allegiance
they're all humans we [ __ ] it I'll stay
with that man life's more interesting
with Batman what about you
ah I will second your emotion sir
ratified cosine cosine sealed and
delivered
excellent question give it up for
everyone ladies Johnny how they should
do the injustice movies instead of what
they've been doing Rock it's a magic
it's creative to where you want to go
next to see more left to this fine
evening folks and left then we send you
all off into the night how are you I'm
doing well thank you
hi oh hey great to see a fan for since
like clerks and Mallrats and it's good
to see you doing I don't even have the
words to say that thank you have a good
question with the Disney and foxy Oh
actually goes through which I hope it
does yes thank you which characters
would you like to see in a film Marvel
control film which characters from Fox
and mixing with MCU characters can you
see maybe like the next phase of the
Avengers being against Galactus yeah
absolutely
and I think I think Kevin foggy would
like nothing but you know that fan OHS
was a big card for them but could you
imagine if it was Galactus or some world
ending event like that who would I like
to see first and foremost I just want to
see them get their house in order maybe
I'm nostalgic but the Marvel Universe
doesn't exist without the Fantastic Four
so
I I have to imagine the architect of the
last 10 years of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has plans in store for Marvel's
first family and restore them to you
know the [ __ ] dignity the wonder the
place in history in comics history that
they have and that's what I look forward
to the most so I'm glad he gets to play
with the x-men and stuff but let's be
honest we've seen some pretty good x-men
movie from time to time and stuff but
we've been waiting for a Fantastic Four
movie a real fantastic mode for a movie
for a long time it's not to take away
from any version that's done before
that's the fan for stick which one fan
for stick the last Fantastic Four that
came out fan for steak that's how that's
how they promoted his fan force days I
mean even that to me had its merits and
stuff each one of them had some [ __ ]
even the Corman version had some charm
to it when I was a kid I couldn't
believe that existed I thought their
thing did look kind of good but and and
the ones they did with Jessica Alba
like they were not [ __ ] horrible I
want to see both of them cinematically
and stuff but they weren't quite what I
hoped they would be the guy who's been
making these Marvel movies for the last
[ __ ] decade if he can't solve that
equation like for I figured not like
this matters and [ __ ] particularly now
that I've seen the other side life and
death and [ __ ] but you know it's been a
long time since we've seen anything
close the Fantastic Four the only one
ever got close was the Incredibles which
we're about to see The Incredibles -
it'd be really nice to see Marvel get to
do their first family and have people
not go oh the greatest Fantastic Four
movie ever made was not a Fantastic Four
movie it was called The Incredibles it's
a small wish it's not gonna change the
world but it's something that like it
just befitting as we've seen every one
of their huge characters step up and
stuff it'd be nice to see them step up
because you don't get anything else at
Marvel unless you know Stan does the
Fantastic Four so they should hopefully
they get to do a version that he gets to
see I would like the guardians of the
galaxy to get a hot tip on some Salvage
on asteroid lv-426
I feel like yeah like you could you
could have a good [ __ ] time with the
alien in the Marvel Universe and I've
read enough of those [ __ ] comic books
at Dark Horse used to put out when it's
like alien it Batman alien and so yeah
[ __ ] it like let's if you're not gonna
do the brood and I mean or you should
just do the brood
you could also instead do the Xenomorphs
and still have a bunch of [ __ ] funny
hey won some tickets give it up for him
ladies and gentlemen he wants a ticket
and we have one more set of tickets
ladies gentlemen who's it gonna be JC
take us there and then take us home all
right friend
hi there uh another first-timer it's
been said several times I'm thrilled
Kevin that you're here reading the news
on my Twitter feed last week made me
realize you know like I love this show
I've been listening to you I've been
listening to the fat man on Batman since
before Mark was I can remember the first
time you were on the show and then it
slowly morphed into what it is now which
is great but it made me realize like
I've been a fan of this stuff for
forever and you know I work eight miles
from here and I've never come to the
show and I was like you know what screw
it I'm going I'm buying tickets even if
I don't know if the shows even gonna
happen but I'm gonna buy tickets a
coggan awesome give it up for and you
know and it's and and you guys say on
the show all the time we live in an
amazing time I mean I'm I'm 44 grew up
reading comic books as a kid and if you
told I say all the time if you told me
20 years ago that we'd be living in a
world where they make serious movies
about guys in tights and that and that
basically the entire industry was run on
it I never would have believed you right
but with Avengers coming up I've got two
boys under 9 and 10 and we started
watching the movies they kind of came in
about midway through the current
incarnation mm-hmm after Black Panther
we decided that we're watching all of
the movies from the beginning to kind of
bone up for two
for Avengers and we watched we're up
through Captain America and something
that made me realize is these movies
even the Oh even the first the first
batch of them have some awesome just
moments and you know one that struck me
was we were watching for which doesn't
get remembered very fondly among all of
them but it doesn't Brahmas movie the
the scene in that movie where the hammer
comes to Thor because he's finally
worthy is just magical to me is great
sequel and I a question for each of you
is of the run of Marvel movies they've
done up through now what's your favorite
kind of just moment that happened on
screen that you would never have thought
would have actually happened in your
lifetime let me see I mean it's the
Marvel movies I could I could probably
give you a handful guardians the galaxy
Peter Quill's mom in the third act when
Kimora's like Peter give me your hand
and he looks over and he sees his mother
going Peter give me her hand it's
[ __ ] fantastic I don't give a [ __ ]
it's a comic book movie that's one of
the greatest moments in cinematic
history it's so [ __ ] powerful and
moving when Tony Stark in the first Iron
Man is about to die in his lab and he
almost reaches you know the [ __ ] the old
the arc reactor that pepper had framed
for him and he just misses it and
[ __ ] goes down and then the robot
gives it to him like I still I get
chills when I [ __ ] think about it
it's so tiny so stupid but so well
earned both of those moments were
layered insanely well throughout the
film so that when they happened they hit
and they kind
it in a really magical way those are two
that leap to the top of my head pan what
about you when Steve Rogers leaps on a
grenade oh so beautiful you beat man I
had to explain that mode that I had to
explain the significance of that to my
ten-year-old like that is the core of
who that character is that is exactly
what makes him tick is the I'm going to
die I'm gonna crawl over a wire so the
other guy can crawl on top of me like
he's that guy and that moment
crystallizes who that character is and
why he deserves the power he gets that's
fantastic storytelling yeah that's so
awesome Tommy Lee Jones grenade and
everybody [ __ ] scatters he jumps onto
it he's like oh oh that and also like in
Civil War when he echoed the sentiment
that he was when he was I could do this
all day yeah well he gets up and he's
like I could do this all day like I'm
telling you man that character really
belongs to what was his name Chris Evans
yeah [ __ ] really and in a special way
I didn't give a [ __ ] I've loved comics
my whole life I could give a [ __ ] about
Captain America never really did much
for me but his portrayal of that
character in all three of those movies
and in the Avengers flicks and it's
evolved as we've seen like throughout
the flux is nothing short of wonderful
he really imbued that character with
hearts so much so that if you're right
and they do [ __ ] wind up killing him
in the next Avengers it's you're gonna
feel a [ __ ] deep loss I know I will
and for that moment alone the
[ __ ] that threw himself on the
grenade and if that's how they send him
out like some fan OHS version of him
throwing himself on the grenade oh my
god I promised them the life of my child
for storytelling that good and moving oh
wow what a great poll that there's that
there's there's I mean it's super
[ __ ] throwaway in the movie I don't
really like but they're just flying yeah
it's just super [ __ ] fun and light
and silly you pick the only good moment
and Thor the door see how I did that so
and there's a moment in thor ragnarok
when when Thor and Loki are in an
elevator and well when you're done with
this you know you'll be done with me and
he's like but you're my brother
like what he has a really wonderful
moment with Thor says that were you know
where he goes Loki I thought the world
of you yeah like you were my brother I
thought that we mourned you when you
died like we I wanted nothing more than
to be your brother for the rest of my
life but you did all of this horrible
[ __ ]
but just now you can even put it like
that it was not judgy way he was like
but at the end of the day you're you and
I'm me and there it is and it's a really
beautiful moment when you think about
what's likely to happen in Avengers I
don't know if I can obviously they were
keeping it under wraps but if if Loki
doesn't die in this battle in either
part 1 or part 2 then I'll eat my
[ __ ] hat because it seems like
there's a thread going through all those
movies and they've kept Tom around for a
long time he's wonderful playing that
part but by the time we got to Ragnarok
you've got the you've got the Genesis
and the seeds of what's ending literally
gonna be a secretary hinted at him dying
yeah almost in virtually every in every
movie and if they if he doesn't if they
do kill Loki and he doesn't ask Thor to
put up a statue with the big bendy hole
I'll be a little disappointed but not
much but yeah I can't imagine they don't
take him out and and what great
storytelling it is man they made me give
a [ __ ] about Loki beyond like the the
funny hat in the comics like they built
that character into something pretty
wonderful yeah and like Anna and I and
one more like I've spoken about it in
the podcast I've written about it but
the beat in Black Panther when they're
piloting the Royal Talent fighter back
into Wakanda and Ocoee is sitting at the
helm and she just turns and she says we
are home mmm like the the idea of home
is incredibly powerful the idea of
here's where I'm from is where my people
are from here's where everything I've
ever known belongs and comes from and
watching it as an African American and
realizing that the connection to what
home is stops for me after a while like
there's of course the house I grew up in
there's the town that I was born in
there's a state I was born in and then I
can't raise my parents back a couple of
generations to where they were born and
then it gets blurry it gets fuzzy it
gets for lack of a better word slaves
should be
it's I don't know that the word [ __ ] its
evocative and so like there's there's an
entire connection to a place that I
don't have where like my wife is Irish
and there was absolutely a town
somewhere in [ __ ] Ireland that she can
follow all the way back there like her
family came over in the third shift
after the Mayflower she's a daughter of
the American Revolution I am NOT a
daughter of anything but so just that
idea of the mythologizing the the
underlining the idea of what home is
and in Wakanda home has never been
broken the connection to that place has
never been fuzzify by history it's never
been erased or it's never been
wallpapered over that it's real for them
in a way that it's not for me and and
just that beat that moment you know
that's when I saw the third time that's
the one that wrecked me and that's the
one that brought me to tears just this
idea of oh [ __ ] why couldn't this be
home and in the absence of any other
home let it be what Conda like why the
hell not I got no place else to call
home so I'm gonna do what Conda
beautiful answer give it up come on and
a great question you get tickets man
well done
pleasure hey let's talk about this
before we go real quick yes sir there
was a piece that was on line last two
days some marketing imagery that was in
a book a Marvel book promoting Avengers
or whatever but basically bless you it
showed all the stones all the Infinity
stones and who the stones were connected
to so obviously this the one that's you
know mind you mind gem they showed
vision for the ether I guess they showed
Thor or whatever [ __ ] right
that was her act was Loki yes but for
the one gem which we haven't seen yet
the one stone in the movie I believe is
the soul stone and we all thought it
would either show up in Black Panther
which it didn't and then a pre or the
other movie what happened right before
that tour yeah and so it didn't play
there as well so in this artwork though
they showed the soul stone and in it the
image connected to it the character
connected to
it was Iron Man huh so it caused a bunch
of folks on the internet wisely to be
like did they just have to put somebody
there or is that clearly connective
tissue meaning is this they've not told
us what the soul stone is it seemed like
you know [ __ ] it was in the heart of the
vibranium meteor that hit Wakanda you
could [ __ ] get away with that but
could it be that Tony Stark's arc
reactor is somehow the soulstone were
the big one that he had but that blew up
they blew up New York and blew that up
an Iron Man and he doesn't have the arc
reactor like he's not wearing it anymore
I know but have you seen in the trailer
you see images of the arc reactor back
in his chest I think that's what I saw
so what could it possibly be if it was
connected to Iron Man like I like the
notion bless you like two weeks ago
somebody said it's a planet like the ego
yeah but I thought like I thought it'd
be badass if it was just earth earth is
the soul stone and that's why he [ __ ]
came here and stuff but what do you
think about that I'm a man soul stone
what would be the connective tissue what
are we missing here I mean unless part
of the narrative of infinity war is
something is wrong again with his heart
and the only way the only thing that he
can use to keep it at bay is an infinity
stone like desperate and with no other
ideas and out of options he rigs up
another [ __ ] chest miracle involving
a soul stone damn it I hate when you
make a better movie than then I have in
my head and maybe then the one will
eventually get man you know but it's
also telling because he's in very I mean
if cap is the heart of the Avengers it's
tempting to say that that Tony is the
mind of the Avengers but I think he's
the soul of the Avengers it's because of
him like and so much of it is because of
his guilt
and as his you know both the sokovia
accords were because of his guilt Ultron
is because of his guilt ultimately him
putting on the [ __ ] suit is because
he's guilty because the dude who helped
him get out of that it is going to die
and die sacrificing himself to break
Tony out of a out of a jail cell like
he's been driven by guilt oh my
can I go back and Rianne sir that
question that's another one of my
favorite moments from Ironman is when
was the guy naming a man named King hope
he you know he winds up getting shot or
whatever and Tony comes in the mark-1
suit and you know he said come on get up
we got to move and he's like you know I
can't he's like this is not the plan
he's like this was always the plan for
me I'm going to see my family they're
all dead and blah blah blah
so Tony realizes he's gonna die right
there and he has a really [ __ ] like
you know a zillion choices he could have
picked for the delivery of the
particular line but it's Robert Downey
jr. when he says to the actor when he
says to that guy goes thank you for
saving my life like it was it's it was
almost a child like delivery and so
[ __ ] pure it's another magic moment
from that [ __ ] movie that Marvel
really knocked out the park and and now
in Repton respect to like [ __ ] what I
went through last week like I know that
feeling
like I I mean when I talked to the
doctor afterwards I was like thanks for
saving my life it's crazy somebody kind
of put themselves in front of you or in
harm's way like they did in that movie
this guy didn't have to take any [ __ ]
bullets he just reached up my dick and
grabbed my heart and seized didn't [ __ ]
like that Mullaly mom was a little bit
more like [ __ ] then I realized ladies
and gentlemen of the scum and villainy
canteen have you had a good time this
evening always a fun show to do
particularly fun to do it at this point
man you know based on what happened last
time and oh my god thank you all for
coming out selling us out we'll be doing
this as frequently as possible because
as I said many times I love doing the
show and there is no show without the
[ __ ] smartest man that I'm standing
next to right now in this room give it
up for Mark Bernard
and that is Batman I'm Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith and I am mark
barnard tune in next week same fat time
same bat Channel SModcast Grom or
YouTube that comes less Kevin Smith
goodnight everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you